lives are changed at the tavistock
center and what happens here has long
drawn attention
questions about how and whether children
should be able to reassign their gender
children like kiera bell who never
imagined her story
would lead her here i'm delighted at the
judgment of the court today
it was a judgment that will protect
vulnerable people i wish it had been
made for me
before i embarked on the devastating
experiment of pb blockers
my life would be very different today
kira was 16 when she went to the
tavistock center
she started receiving hormone blockers
and later surgery to become
quincy she regretted the decision and
today
in a landmark ruling a judge said her
case had shown it's doubtful
14 and 15 year olds could understand
long-term risks of treatment
and highly unlikely children under 13
can give
competent consent i was extremely upset
and you know just realizing
how traumatic the experience was and um
how deceitful i feel that the clinicians
were during my care
um so yeah it was it was heartbreaking
medical transition doesn't have to be
be the way for you you know you can come
out of this the other end
the less public face of this was known
in court as woman a
she's always gravitated towards male
friends they just seem to accept her far
more than the girls
a woman whose daughter is on the waiting
list for treatment
when it comes to this any parent whose
child presents like this and has any
concern and reservations
we're told to dismiss those concerns and
reservations and just go with it and
ignore the doubts that we've got and the
feeling that
it doesn't sit right we're told to
sideline that and just go with it and
that's
very difficult as a parent which one's
your favorite
out of all of those but many have a very
different story
alex was 13 when he went to the
tavistock with his mother's support
it took me 18 months to get onto
blockers and then it would normally take
people two years just to get
seen so you can imagine it takes a long
time and that's a significant
amount of puberty that's happening with
bringing with a significant amount of
dysphoria and therefore distress
i'm up to the point now where i can live
my life as a normal person and like
being trans doesn't even factor into my
life
well it does a little bit but like the
idea that i can live a normal life
regardless of that
is absolutely amazing for me you know i
just listened to alex and followed
through with kind of
what what was right for him
and you know here we are today and
that's you know that's the amazing thing
is that you've been able to
um sort of deal with these issues
and put it behind me and put it behind
us and now you know you
just you are amazing you know he is
an outstanding young person
this family isn't alone stonewall found
that in 2016-17
less than one percent of those who went
to the tavistock experienced regret
after transitioning they say they
provide
a thoughtful and measured service the
tavistock knows clinics
around the world will be watching a
landmark case that's likely to be a
moment of change in transgender
treatment
ali fortescue sky news